la première famille que nous allons
visiter avec ici dans l'arrondissement
rosemont petite patrie
ils sont trois ils ont une petite fille
de trois ans ils n'ont pas de voiture et
pour réduire leur empreinte carbone
il essaye de réduire au strict minimum
leur production déchets on a une
poubelle
là je l'échangé le 28 novembre dernier
puis la dernière poubelle donc trois
semaines on a produit moins de 21 litres
et on produit à peu près 20 litres de
déchets compostables chaque semaine on
limite aussi justement la produc et le
gaspillage alimentaire chaque québécois
produit plus de 720 kg de déchets par
année et 50 % ses déchets pourrait être
compostés on peut réduire davantage
notre empreinte carbone et on essaie de
le faire avec des petits gestes très
simples à la maison tous les jours
c'est quoi cette sieste sur la vallée
résumé 2,3 exemple par exemple des
mouchoirs en tissu des débarbouillettes
lavables j'ai une fille elle elle a eu
des couches lavables
je vais faire mes courses je vais
acheter du pain j'ai des petits sacs en
tissu je peux mettre mon pain
directement dedans je vais acheter des
fruits je prends des fruits sans
emballage j'achète en prêt
notre deuxième famille vit dans un
contexte bien différent il habite la
banlieue ici à brossard ils sont 8 2
adulte 6 enfant
deux voitures et un poisson rouge se
sent fin je n'emploie temps partiel ma
conjointe est temps plein c'est beaucoup
l'implication très grosse coordination
cantonale chaque fille de 6 ans est-ce
que ça devient priorité 2 et comment je
peux résumer mon empreinte carbone ou
est-ce qu'on n'a pas le temps de penser
à tout ça envieux non si certains trucs
qu'on veut faire un but d'aider qu'ils
vont être capables de rentrer dans notre
cousin ce serait enfin tu peux tous les
prendre si tu veux non tu me laisses
d'accord rené vous êtes un spécialiste
qui venez avec nous pour mesurer
l'impact de ses efforts pour réduire
l'empreinte carbone c'est clair que le
tout sous l'eau c'est un des grands un
des grands responsables de l'empreinte
environnementale
donc tout ce qu'on peut faire en
transport actif que ce soit à pied ou à
vélo c'est bien une voiture qui consomme
par exemple 10 litres d'essence par 100
km va produire une tonne de co2 à chaque
fois qu'elle franchit trois mille
kilomètres depuis le début des années 90
on a ajouté deux millions de véhicules
sur les routes du québec
le nombre de voitures augmentent trois
fois plus vite que la population
le grand responsable au niveau de
l'habitation s'est beaucoup le chauffage
de l'eau et de l'air à ceux ci l usage
dans une maison au québec environ 60% de
l'énergie utilisée uniquement pour
chauffer des pièces colmater les fuites
d'air le long des murs des fenêtres ou
des portes permet de réduire de 40% les
pertes de chaleur et on change ça ici
mais ont changé le bot porte ici
d'autres s'isolent beaucoup mieux
l'époque est entièrement mais je vous
montrais permet aussi aux mousses
isolantes qu'ils ont c'est tout simple
c'est tout simple
jean paul audel faible consommation
minuterie donc pour vous un autre truc
c'est de mettre des plastiques pour
mieux isoler les flics sont exposés
au niveau de l'épicerie forcément on a
beaucoup plus de peau on prend des pots
en verre directement pour pour conserver
une alimentation qui va être
majoritairement carnivores plutôt que
végétarienne a aussi un plus grand
impact
une plus grande empreinte
environnementale parce que vous limitez
la consommation de chez vous oui ça fait
très longtemps
tout simplement on aime on aime la
viande mais ça arrive ce soit une fois
par semaine ça peut être des fois aux
deux semaines qu'on mange de la viande
si une famille de quatre mange un steak
de moins par semaine ça équivaut à
retirer une voitures de la circulation
pendant trois mois dans votre gosse
attrait c'est pourquoi on est des
carnivores pavillon maison que ce soit
les potages au lithium pas des plus
grandes quantités dans le but d'apporter
le lendemain pour le lunch
on a eu beau mais moi je pense que ce
qui compte c'est que chacun puisse soit
capable de faire un petit geste puis
faire un petit geste c'est toujours
mieux que rien faire et dans sa prise de
conscience pourquoi est-ce que c'était
parfait pince
c'est l'avenir 2 au maintien